[Music]
buckle your seat belts
we're about to take a ride on the cosmic
super highway
what exactly are these celestial
autobahns how would they help us
explore the furthest parts of our solar
system
and could they change our approach to
mapping the cosmos
forever this is what if
and here's what would happen if we built
a highway
in space i know what you're thinking and
no we aren't talking about laying down
pavement
to build some kind of outer space
freeway
though there is at least one tesla that
would be happy about the idea
the space pathways we're talking about
are called space
manifolds these are arch-like structures
that
emerge from the complicated
gravitational pull between the sun
planets and their moons if you found
yourself
on one of these many interplanetary jet
streams
could you effortlessly cruise our solar
system
or could one wrong turn slam you head
first into jupiter
we've built highways all over earth and
the only thing you need to get started
on your journey
would be a road map when it comes to
space navigating would be a little more
complicated but
you could save a lot on fuel but it's
not just about saving on fuel money you
know we might be building highways in
space but
we aren't moving out of earth just yet
we need to keep
our planet healthy and you can do your
part too with wren
our friends and sponsors of this episode
ren
is a website where you can check your
carbon footprint and find ways to keep
our environment healthy all you need to
do is
answer a few questions about your
lifestyle then wren calculates your
carbon footprint and
gives you tips on how to reduce it then
you can offset what's left by
funding projects that plant trees and
help protect the rainforests
ren helps you be more conscious about
the climate crisis and
helps you do something good for the
planet too once you sign up for a
monthly contribution to offset your
carbon footprint
you receive monthly updates on the
projects you support so
you get to see where your money is spent
you get pictures of the trees that were
planted how cool is that
ending the climate crisis won't be easy
but
you can start making your small steps
today
we at what if have partnered with wren
to protect five extra acres of
rainforest
for the first 100 people who sign up
using our referral link
in the description below check ren.co
and start making a difference today okay
now let's get back to our interplanetary
highways
like i said navigating these freeways
would be
a little complicated well quite
complicated i should say
that's because you'd be utilizing the
concept of gravity assist
this is a reliable technique that is
already vital to space exploration
if you were on a spacecraft using
gravity assist
you could travel much further than your
launch vehicle could
well launch you imagine using the sun
and planets like a slingshot to propel
yourself
around the solar system you'd add or
subtract momentum by
increasing or decreasing the energy of
your
orbit these techniques have been applied
on previous missions like
voyager 2 this outer planet probe was
launched in 1977
and got a trajectory boost from the
gravitational pulls of
both saturn and uranus and now
it's still speeding through interstellar
space after
more than 40 years of service
but navigating the cosmic super highway
system
would be a little more complicated than
using the gravity of just one
planet these pathways are generated from
the complex gravitational interactions
between all the planets their moons and
the sun
and for starters they're nearly
invisible
if you could spot them you'd be looking
at a network of
tubes swirling along with the planets
but just because they're hard to see
doesn't mean you couldn't try
it would be important to familiarize
yourself with lagrange points
for any two-body system like the earth
and the moon or
the sun and jupiter there are five
locations in space
where gravitational forces between the
two are in
equilibrium or simply balanced
if you could place your spacecraft on
one of these points
then you'd be able to remain in a stable
orbit
no need to worry about being pushed
further into space
or being pulled in to crash and
since all two-body systems have these
points
that means our solar system is full of
them
as planets orbit the sun these points
overlap
and intersect so if you're paying
attention you could time things
just right to jump off to another
planet's orbit
[Music]
hopping through space on these super
highways would allow you to save a lot
of money on fuel
while reaching the outermost parts of
the solar system
at breakneck speeds if you found
yourself
on the right route you could travel the
3.7
billion kilometers from jupiter to
neptune
in less than 10 years but
i hope you've got a few years or even
decades to spare
just waiting for these points to overlap
in a good way
and you're still going to need a ship
big enough for all the cargo you'd be
carrying
nasa has estimated that crew of four on
a three-year mission
would need to take more than 10 800
kilograms of food
but if you could use this cosmic highway
trips that usually take hundreds of
thousands of years
could be reduced to several decades
even though scientists have utilized
these manifolds on
previous missions it's unlikely they'll
be trying
crude missions any time soon to truly
understand the complex map of
connections
we'd need to study many of the millions
of objects floating through space like
comets and asteroids right you wouldn't
want to smash into the surface of
jupiter if your
calculations didn't add up and this kind
of studying
could help detect potentially dangerous
space objects hurtling along the
celestial autobahn
straight towards earth you know all this
space travel
makes me think maybe instead of space
shuttles or rockets
we could build a tower reaching all the
way out into space
[Music]
i know i know that's a story
for another what if